>>Female presenter: So I wanted to introduce
all of you to Rebecca MacKinnon who is here
to talk about her new book, Consent of the
Networked.
Rebecca is currently a senior fellow at the
New America Foundation and also a co-founder
of Global Voices which is a citizen journalism
network and she also had a stint at the Berkman
Center at Harvard.
But before that Rebecca was a foreign correspondent
for CNN in China and Japan and has an incredibly
impressive career; she also speaks fluent
Mandarin.
And Rebecca's also on the board of the Committee
to Protect Journalists and the Global Network
Initiative of which Google is also a founding
member.
So she's here to talk about her book which
I have to urge all of you to read because
I think it's the, it's the book I wish I had
written.
It's an incredibly thoughtful take on the
overall state of Internet freedom around the
world and what roles that governments and
companies and citizens play in shaping that
future.
So please give a warm welcome to Rebecca.
[applause]
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Thank you.
Thank you very much for having me here today.
It's funny when I started planning to write
the book and then started writing the book
it was before the Arab Spring happened so
and then as the Arab Spring was happening
in January and February, I was kind of realizing
I had to kind of reframe the book slightly
based on what had happened.
But it was also an incredible opportunity
to really show in very current impressing
way why these issues matter.
And I guess Wael Ghonim came here recently
or he's coming, he came two days ago.
And in the beginning of the book I talk about
the Internet and social media obviously played
some role in the Arab Spring, there's still
a lot of debate about how big a role, etcetera,
etcetera and people are going to be arguing
about that for a long time.
And Wael Ghonim famously said to CNN right
after Mubarak stepped down, "If you wanna
liberate a society just give them the Internet."
And it's turning out to be a little more complicated
than that especially in Egypt as they're really
struggling to actually institute a democracy
despite having used the Internet to say no
to a nasty regime.
How do you then use the Internet to build
a robust and functional democracy is a much
bigger question not only in Egypt but also
in Tunisia where now that they've got a democratically
elected constituent assembly that's writing
a new constitution they're having arguments
about what should the role of censorship and
surveillance be in a democratic society.
And actually some censorship in Tunisia has
been reinstated for kind of moral, ethical
reasons; people in a conservative Islamic
society don't want their children looking
at porn and so how do you decide what the
mechanism should be and how do you prevent
them from getting abused in a way that kind
of takes you at least some steps back to where
you came from and away from where you're trying
to go as a democracy?
And unlike a general audience you guys have
already, of course, think a lot about these
issues but increasingly the citizens no matter
whether we're Tunisians or Americans or French
people or whatever our relationship with government,
our political live are sort of remediated
through the collection of technologies and
services and platforms that make up the Internet.
And so what my book is really about is not
the question of does the Internet help the
good guys more than the bad guys or is it
making us stupid or is it used more for good
or more for evil, but how do we insure that
the Internet evolves in way that best serves
the rights and interests of citizens?
And how do we make sure that the Internet
moves in a manner, evolves in a manner that
is compatible with democracy here in the United
States and compatible with the democratic
aspirations of people around the world which
many people continue to risk their lives for
everyday?
And of course as company how does one support
that while still being a profitable business
is of course a challenging question.
And I deal in the book quite a bit about kind
of change in the nature of sovereignty and
power.
And so in the physical world of course we
have sovereign governments running countries
and if you're lucky you're in a democracy
where you actually vote for your leaders and
you can vote them out of office if they're
really awful or at least in theory, and you
can, there might be some way to hold the government
accountable.
But that also that the laws being passed by
the government are affecting the citizens
in that country right?
But now you have a situation, and we saw this
with SOPA, the Stop Online Piracy Act, and
PIPA, the Senate version, where you have a
law passed by Congress which is elected by
Americans which potentially, it fortunately
wasn't passed, but could potentially have
affected the rights and freedoms of Internet
users all over the world who didn't vote for
these people and have no way of holding them
accountable and who don't really necessarily
care whether Indonesians are hurt by the law
they passed 'cause they really only care,
frankly, about their own constituents.
I mean there may be some who care, but ultimately
their jobs do not depend on whether or not
they're affecting the rights of people in
Indonesia or Brazil or elsewhere.
So that's kind of a sovereignty mismatch that's
going on that has been exacerbated by the
Internet in terms of being able to hold state
power accountable against abuse of people
who use the Internet.
The mechanisms of nation-state democracy even
when they are working perfectly aren't, don't
really solve, answer that question for us.
And then, of course, you have the overlapping
private sovereignties of companies and I love
this map this is the latest version of the
world map of social networks and everything
blue on this map is countries where Facebook
is the most popular social network.
And as we saw in the Arab Spring and with
the work of Wael Ghonim and others, that people
used this globally, interconnected network
called Facebook, this platform, to challenge
the sovereignty and legitimacy of their government
in a way that was very exciting.
But you also have the companies making decisions
that may or may not always be compatible with
the rights and interests of their users.
So for instance, to continue on with the Facebook
example I talk about lots of companies including
Google in the book, but to continue on with
the Facebook example, Facebook's privacy policies.
They may work in certain contexts but if you
change the privacy policies suddenly and expose
people's friends' networks what does that
mean for an Iranian activist who doesn't want
their friends to go to jail for being associated
with them?
And to what extent have the people at the
company thinking about the product and trying
to make it profitable considered some of the
life and death consequences of their choices?
And so it's kind of both negative and positive.
And then of course the big red there is China
with Facebook being blocked and of course
no need to tell the story of Google's experience
in China where Baidu is now the dominant search
engine and kind of is solidified because of
what's happened recently.
But also in Russia you have Russian social
networks are the predominant networks at the
moment.
And there have been some troubling things
going on despite kind of the protests and
hopeful things happening, there is some real
questions about the relationship between the
Russian government and the social networking
companies and the extent to which the Russian
security services are accessing information
in a manner that is not helpful to the democracy
movement there just to put it mildly.
So you've got again this question of how do
you hold Internet companies accountable to
users' interests and then how does the kind
of the private governance that's going on
overlap with the governance that's happening,
that's being conducted by nation states and
then how that plays out both within countries
and globally.
So I use a phrase which Bob Boorstin doesn't
like very much but we still speak anyway,
"the sovereigns of cyberspace," and how yes
companies, [phone rings] oops, I better silence
my phone.
Companies cannot tax people and they cannot
put them in jail so one can carry the analogy
too far.
But large global Internet companies and platforms
are playing a kind of governance function
because they are having an impact on what
people can and cannot know, how they organize
in real life, how their identities are manifested
in their communities which has a lot of real
life implications and ultimately can have
a lot of political implications and implications
for people's freedoms.
And this whole question of to what extent
are these sort of benevolent kings or kings
that claim to be benevolent, and is that enough,
is that acceptable enough in this world today
when we rejected the divine right of kings
some time ago in real life?
And just to kind of reinforce kind of the
sovereignty problems that I was talking about,
again the Internet primarily comprised of
corporate platforms and services and so on,
there's obviously some non-profit and decentralized
non-corporate things going on as well, but
most citizens their relationship with their
government is mediated through these platforms
and services that are owned and operated by
the private sector in different ways.
And so in a kind of standard democratic kind
of setup within a democracy ideally what happens
is that we vote for our elected representatives
and then if a company is doing something that
hurts us, let's say the milk has chemicals
in it that's creating disease or a company
is employing 10 year olds or something like
that, the government then goes and regulates
the company and that kind of serves the interests
and kind of holds everybody accountable because
accountability is going through the elected
democratic government.
That's the ideal it never works out perfectly
but that's the ideal and it's kind of basically
in the pre-Internet age kind of made sense
and sort of worked as much as it could as
any human system ever works.
But we have a number of problems: one is that
increasingly you have companies, with SOPA
and PIPA that was a very clear thing, the
extent to which corporations influenced legislation
and that may or may not take into account
the rights and interests of a lot of other
stakeholders.
And so in that case, and then also you have
a situation where companies particularly technology
and information companies, Internet companies,
are also shaping kind of how we conduct our
campaigns, how we conduct our activism, what
we know, how we know it, who we know, what
people know about us, and so on.
So they're kind of shaping our lives as well.
And so one of the things I raise in my book
is do we need to have citizens kind of taking
their concerns more directly to the companies
more often because one of the problems with
regulation, I mean you could just be calling
for the government to regulate Google and
everybody else more because Google's not doing
this, that, or the other properly, but there
are a lot of problems with regulation.
It tends to be ham-fisted, it tends to, it
may or may not solve the problem, it may be
counterproductive.
Are there ways to kind of, for companies to
engage with their constituents, with their
stakeholders earlier in the process of innovation
and product development to anticipate problems
that would end up enabling you to avoid people
calling for you to get regulated in the first
place?
If you kind of talk to people about what their
concerns are gonna be and the question about
how you do that and we've had some conversations
more directly about we're in very early days
about thinking about how a company might do
that.
You also have the problem, like I said before,
of governments passing laws and doing things
that influence people who have no control
over what they do and a company in one country
is influencing people around the world whose
experiences they might not understand or really
relate to in any way.
And so then it almost becomes even more important
to the people around the world since they
can't do anything about what that government's
doing but they might be able to engage with
the company that interfaces with that government.
Can that government, can that company sometimes
act as an advocate for users who are not from
that country that is passing the laws?
And that's also an interesting question to
think about.
So after I've shown that really excessively
complicated graphic I'm going to show a funny
video from Monty Python and The Holy Grail
which I think kind of outlines one of the
core points of the book.
So here we go.
[video playing]
>>Peasant: The two-thirds majority in the
case of all others
>>King: Be quiet.
I order you to be quiet.
>>Peasant: Order? who does he think he is?
[chuckles]
>>King: I'm your king.
>>Peasant: Well, I didn't vote for you.
>>King: You don't vote for kings.
>>Peasant: Well, how'd you become king then.
>>King: The Lady of the Lake, [ethereal music
plays] her arm clad in the purest shimmering
samite held aloft Excalibur from the bosom
of the water signifying by divine providence
that I, Arthur, was to carry Excalibur.
That is why I am your king.
>>Peasant: Listen, strange women lying in
ponds, distributing swords is no basis for
a system of government.
Supreme executive power derives from a mandate
from the masses not from some farcical, aquatic
ceremony.
>>King: Be quiet!
>>Peasant: You can't expect to wield supreme
executive power just 'cause some watery tart
threw a sword at you.
>>King: Shut up!!
[laughter]
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Well this is one of my
favorite Monty Python clips of all time and
so I just love the fact that I can actually
use it to illustrate a point in my book.
The point of it is that, one reason why it's
so funny, is that it juxtaposes two completely
different ways of thinking about power and
sovereignty and the way in which governance
happens.
And the first way is the divine right of kings
and there was a point in time where everybody
in the world was basically governed by some
king, sultan, whatever Khan, whatever it was
and most of these rulers were claiming divine
authority, emperor, to rule their subjects.
And it was assumed this was the only way to
govern anything and that's how power worked
and that's how the world was.
And that evolved, we had political innovation
or political evolution or whatever you wanna
call it.
In modern times it began in part with the
Magna Carta when the barons of England kind
of decided that this divine right of kings
thing was not working for them very well and
King John was a real jerk and he needed to
be bound by laws and otherwise they weren't
going to be loyal to him.
And that kind of evolved over time to the
concept several hundred years later with John
Locke and kind of articulating the notion
of consent of the governed and that government
does not derive its mandate from the masses
is illegitimate.
And then it took a bit longer for a revolution
here in the United States, in America as it
was called then, to happen and for the first
effort to actually implement consent of the
governed in real life.
And now kind of globally, even countries that
aren't democratic still claim that they are
governing with the consent and sometimes come
up with really elaborate sham mechanisms to
prove this; fake elections and all kinds of
different things.
And so consent of the governed we're sort
of now, I argue in the book, we're kind of
at a new Magna Carta moment where consent
of the governed based on the nation state
is kind of the assumed way of how you organize
power and how you hold power accountable.
But we're starting to recognize that that's
not working for us so well anymore for all
the reasons I talked about earlier that one
nation state exercises power over technology
and then it has effects on people elsewhere
and they're not held accountable.
And you have private corporations that may
be well meaning but are making decisions that
have all kinds of different effects and that
sometimes the constituent users find legitimate
and good and other times find to be quite
illegitimate.
And how do we build mechanisms that actually
constrain the use of power across a globally
networked world, across this global digital
network, and how do you hold power accountable
across a global digital network?
And we don't have mechanisms to do that.
The current sort of structure of politics
and geopolitics and governance and business
practices and corporate structures is not
working for that and we don't have a lot of
answers.
I don't have sort of Rebecca MacKinnon's solution
for like how to build consent of the network
and some kind of grand scheme, I'm calling
on people to figure it out.
But the first step is recognizing that there's
been a change and we need to work for it.
And just kind of quickly before I close there's
an analogy that I first heard from a professor
at the University of Austin, Texas named Rosental
Alves who talks about how the pre-Internet
age was an information desert.
And so governance, accountability, sort of
our whole way of organizing our reality and
our knowledge about reality was based on scarcity
and based on the management of scarce informational
resources.
And then suddenly the rain came with the Internet
and we're now living in a rain forest and
the ways of organizing civilization that worked
well enough or made sense in the desert are
not working in the rain forest so well.
And we have all kinds of new organisms that
have built up and so how do we build a civilization
in cyberspace that is respectful of the rights
of all of its members and that you can govern
it but it's governed in a manner that's fair
for all of its members and in which the abuse
of power and force is constrained to an adequate
degree?
And we're not sure how to do that yet.
Also in the book I talk about the importance
of the Digital Commons and this is something
that Google has been very supportive of in
terms of open source software and open source
communities and free content communities or
content sharing communities.
And all the people who are producing both
standards as well as code as well as content
on the Web who are doing so for reasons other
than financial motive, without which, without
this robust community not only would we have
no Internet but it would be much harder for
civil society to do what they do today on
the Internet.
And I co-founded this organization Global
Voices which runs on WordPress and there are
a lot of activist communities around the world
that would not be functioning online if it
were not for open source, developers, and
communities that continue to make those products
better.
So the importance of the Digital Commons in
sort of keeping global, digital, civil society
and dissent and discourse alive being really
important.
And then just in closing there are various
experiments, there's ICANN is one experiment
to deal with one specific set of issues in
governing specific Internet resources related
to domain names and matching them with IP
addresses and coordinating that.
And there are a lot of problems with ICANN,
but it's a multi-stakeholder model and is
trying to kind of insist on remaining multi-stakeholder
despite a lot of pressure from a lot of governments
to basically hand over its functions to the
United Nations.
And the important of bringing in civil society
groups in addition to companies to kind of
work out how the Internet should be coordinated
going forward being really important.
And you're seeing more groups kind of coming
up with bills of rights and declaring their
rights and saying, "Look the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights can actually apply to the
Internet and should and here are guidelines
for how governments and companies can take
Universal Rights and apply them to both their
lawmaking and their corporate operations."
You have efforts like the Global Network Initiative,
that Google's a member of, to bring companies
together, commit to basic standards on free
expression, privacy, and other aspects of
human rights and work proactively with civil
society groups and socially responsible investors
to try and anticipate problems and also kind
of work together to figure out how do you
respond to really difficult challenges, and
how do you think through the human rights
implications of your business in advance of
problems emerging, and how do you address
them the problems when they emerge?
Google's Transparency Report, I think that
all companies ought to be releasing something
similar.
Again it's really important that citizens
understand kind of how government power and
corporate power over their information is
interfacing 'cause I think it's where that
intersection happens where a lot of troubling
things can take place.
And so the extent to which companies can be
transparent about what governments are demanding
and how people's information is accessed and
how it's used I think is critically important.
And another thing that Google's been doing
a fair amount of is with Google+ for instance
there've been a number of executives who've
been working very hard to kind of talk to
user communities and talk to critics and get
that feedback and try and improve on some
of the problems that have come up.
And we were having a conversation earlier
about how to systematize that more and really
use conversations with stakeholders and communities
to improve the product, anticipate problems,
build trust.
You're also, of course, seeing a lot, more
and more company-targeted activism.
I think it's a real trend that more and more
people, activist groups that have been, up
until recently, primarily targeting their
activism to government are gonna be targeting
Internet companies more and more and so that's
an interesting trend to watch and to figure
out how to kind of interface with that.
And, of course, I think finally with the SOPA/PIPA
thing publics, voting publics, are becoming
more aware of how Internet related legislation
is affecting them.
I think people haven't been paying too much
attention, I think they're starting to and
it's going to be very interesting to see if
Internet rights become more of a mainstream
political issue and how that affects our politics
and how that affects kind the role that companies
play in that political discussion in this
country and around the democratic world.
So with that I end with my favorite picture
from the Occupy Wall Street Movement with
this guy who has a sign there, "Let's get
our s-h-i-t, let's figure this s-h-i-t out
together."
The point being is we're recognizing, I think,
we're at a point it's not just when it comes
to the Internet but when it comes to all kinds
of issues in terms of the global economy,
in terms of the way global governance works,
a lot of things aren't working so well for
a lot of people on the planet and how do we
work out solutions?
And we need to figure this out together; civil
society, companies, how do we create a planet
that's more sustainable and that is the kind
of society that we want to live in not only
sustainable in terms of environmentally or
our resources, but also how do companies contribute
to a society that we want politically, the
kind of freedoms that we want, that we aspire
to have?
And how do we make sure that companies are
part of this ecosystem to insuring that democracy
is as robust and healthy as possible and not
inadvertently contributing actually to the
weakening of democracy in different ways and
the extent to which it's important that companies
be thinking about that as much as they're
thinking about, "How am I contributing to
a sustainable environment or healthy work
force?" or all these other things that companies
have come to think about which they didn't
think about at all 100 years ago; it wasn't
considered the business of business but now
is.
So kind of privacy, human rights, freedom
of expression is now kind of entering into
I think very early days of people realizing
that this is yet another part of being a sustainable
business.
So with that, thank you very much.
I talked a little longer than I planned but
I hope it was interesting and I look forward
to your questions or comments or objections,
whatever it is.
[applause]
>>male #1: Hi.
So your rhetorical context seems to be that
democracy is in some sense the natural terminal
point of political development and that American
corporations are sort of the natural terminal
point of economic development.
But then you undermine yourself by going on
to point out that the powers that are exerted
by government are not well matched with the
--
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Right.
>>male #1: people who actually vote for them.
There also seems to be a contradiction in
the very basis that governments maybe it is
good for them to be democratic but corporations
are meritocratic --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
>>male #1: perhaps with some bizarre metrics.
But how can one be right for government and
the other be right for business?
I guess what I'm trying to ask is --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>male #1: if I analyze what you're saying
as closely as I can from what I've heard today,
why is the space of solutions so small, why
are we talking about governments and corporations
--
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
>>male #1: when in fact it looks as if informed
decision making is really the problem that
we're trying to solve --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
>>male #1: and at this point I would like
to say something nice about China who at least
seem to be trying to find that solution even
if they haven't got there yet and may not
get there for a long time.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
Yeah, well, thanks for that.
I lived in China for nine years and so that's
definitely something one could talk about
for a long time, about the intentions of the
government and to what extent.
Obviously China's a much more complex place
then is kind of discussed, I think, in a lot
of the media.
But I guess this question about democracy,
when I talk about democracy as an ideal and
I guess that's part of the problem of giving
a short talk, I mean sort of democracy with
a small 'd' as opposed to democracy as the
United States currently practices it institutionally.
And I'm not sure, maybe there's a better system
of holding power in check, I just don't know
what it is.
I started my academic career studying the
origins of the Chinese and Russian Revolutions
and the origins of Marxism and sort of Communist
revolutions.
And so therefore, I must admit, I'm deeply
suspicious of Utopian philosophies that kind
of seek to kind of provide a total solution
or that are based on the idea that human nature
can change.
It's just everything I've studied and everything
I've experienced personally having lived in
China for a very long time and also spent
a little time in Russian and having just studied,
kind of, what went on; and my parents actually
wrote a book about a Communist journalist
in the 30's and 40's who was involved with
several Communist movements at the time.
And so I guess I've been exposed a lot to
how idealist the Socialist movements were
at the turn of the last century and how badly
wrong they went and how horribly they were
abused by evil people.
And so, I guess, where I end up philosophically
is that democracy kind of as an ideal is a
horribly, imperfect thing.
But I haven't come across anything, I tend
to buy into the notion that we have to assume
in our system of government, any system of
government, that people are gonna abuse power
and that people are gonna act in their own
self interest and that you need to create
a system that kind sets up checks and constraints,
and that as human beings that's the best we're
ever gonna be able to hope for unless human
nature changes which I'm not counting on and
which I think basing a system of political
movement on is dangerous.
So I'd love to hear other ideas about other
political systems that might work better but
I'm deeply suspicious of anything I've heard
so far that isn't small 'd' democratic and
kind of small 'l' liberal and that's just
where I come from philosophically.
And I guess then, again with corporations,
having spent time in the Communist world,
I do think that capitalism needs to survive,
it needs to change, it needs to evolve, it's
not currently in the way it's practiced in
many forms healthy.
But again what are the alternatives?
State run economies, I just know too many
people who have suffered under that kind of
system.
So I guess my hope is that we can find a way
to evolve private enterprise in a manner that's
sustainable and evolve small 'd' democracy
in a manner that works in a globally networked
world.
And it is messy and I guess that's just sort
of the nature of where we are now that it
does seem contradictory [laughs] because the
ideologies that have kind of been the norm
aren't necessarily producing the best results.
Yet all the ideological and kind of systemic
alternatives that I know of as they've been
practiced to date have resulted in much greater
evil in my opinion.
And China to the extent that it is gonna work
out I think is moving away from those ideologies
and those systems rather than re-embracing
them.
So yeah, but it's tough and I really appreciate
the points you made because had I been a really
rigorous political scientist and theorist
rather than writing a more kind of populist,
general book I think I would have quickly
gotten twisted around on the theory.
[laughs] So you're absolutely right to point
that out.
Um-hum.
>>male #2: Hi, thanks again for coming.
So my question is really about the consent
of the governed --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
>>male #2: concept.
So I think all of us here, especially people
involved in developing products, I wouldn't
be surprised if people here feel that like
our users actually consent to use us --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
>>male #2: way more than I, as a citizen,
consent to almost --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>male #2: anything my government does.
I mean on a daily basis a user's consenting
to use Google, for example.
And so I guess I'm interested to tease out
a little bit more, I think that there's something
to it I'm just interested to tease out --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>male #2: a little bit more like what, what
is the thing that you're worried about that
Google doesn't, needs more consent for somehow.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
Oh that's a really good, that's a really good
question.
Yeah and there's obviously a lot of problems
with democratic consent as practiced for exactly
the reason you point out, that most people
are not exercising their ability to reinforce
consent or withdraw consent they're just kind
of apathetic.
And so to the extent that you're apathetic
is the extent to which you get the government
you deserve I would argue.
[laughs]
And it's absolutely true people are clicking
through to terms of service and so on, but
then there are a lot of things that I think
people are just kind of sticking with even
though they're uncomfortable and unhappy with
them because they're on the service and it's
such a pain to leave and I hear this from
people who use Facebook all the time.
"Like, I need to be on Facebook because all
my friends are there," or "because I'm an
environmental activist and running this campaign
I have to do it on Facebook, but this that
and the other thing deeply troubles me and
I don't know what to do."
You hear that a lot.
And so with the Google+ thing, for instance,
there were a lot of people who said, "Who
are you to say that?"
So say there's an Iranian activist who has
a persistent online identity, Vahid Online,
it's obviously not his real name and he got
kicked off of Google+ and the issue is to
what extent this, and we've had conversations
about this in private, but to what extent
does this--.
Yeah I mean he probably did click on some
terms of service he didn't read and he doesn't
have to use it, nobody's forcing him to, but
if he's also been kicked off of Facebook and
everything else --
[pause]
would Google in the long run benefit from
developing a product in a way that has kind
of more proactive buy in from its users so
that they feel that the policies that are
being developed really kind of respect their
rights and interests?
And how you do that, of course, is I think
we're still in really early days of figuring
that out.
I kind of feel and I certainly hope that the
companies that figure that out more than their
competitors or faster than their competitors,
are going to have a real advantage in terms
of the trust and buy in that they earn from
people who use their products.
I'm very much hoping that that will be kind
of part of the value that companies create
and a sort of innovation in a way.
But yeah, 'cause at the same time taking a
product development decision to a vote of
your users is, I mean, that would be ludicrous
right?
[someone talking in background]
But then the issue is, and this kinda gets
beyond the consent or at least the majority
consent question because if you're, coming
back to sort of physical governance, if you're
trying to run a democracy in which unpopular
minorities can also exist or people with really
niche or we might say long tail concerns,
if you're trying to create a society in which
those people can be heard and have the space
to exist and aren't squeezed out or living
in fear or whatever, completely marginalized,
how do you structure that and how do you provide
the mechanisms for those people's rights to
speak, to exist, to own property, to run a
business, to publish, remain very protected
despite the fact that maybe the majority of
people in that community might think that
they're completely illegitimate and should
have no right to exist and don't like them
at all?
[laughs]
But the extent to which a society kinda protects
the right to exist and the right to thrive
of its most kind of marginalized and vulnerable
members I think is important and as we, and
then again sort of overlapping it, things
like Google on top of our attempt to continue
to have the democracy when the public's fear
is kind of engaged primarily through these
spaces and political campaigns and activism
and so on, how do you ensure that those people
whose rights we want to be protected in real
life have a place to exist in these digital
spaces?
And then how do you kind of consult with them
and learn about their concerns, find a way
to take their situation into account?
And so that kind of goes beyond consent theory
to other stuff but I think as we're thinking
about just how to be compatible with democracy,
which may or may not have anything to do with
running a profitable business, [laughs] what
needs to be taken into consideration?
>>female #1: So I wanted to ask you a question
that is a little bit off the core of your
book --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
>>female #1: which focuses on governments
and Internet software companies.
I wanted to ask you about some of the developments
over the last year that we've learned about
in regards to surveillance --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
>>female #1: by governments.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>female #1: Blue Coat --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum..
>>female #1: in Syria --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>female #1: Cisco in China and that New York
Times' story from a couple of weeks ago about
Apple and the iPhone which was a --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>female #1: fascinating story, but to me
really captured a conversation and a debate
that has been going on that predates the Internet.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>female #1: It goes down to the whole question
of sweat shops --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>female #1: and foreign workers -
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
>>female #1: and what the role of governments
are in Western democracies --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>female #1: that, where companies are based
and yet use the labor of companies that are
in regimes that are less open.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>female #1: What's your take on that?
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Well, I mean the Apple
case just to kind of start from there is,
Apple is reviled within the socially responsible
investment community [laughs] for exactly
the sweat shop reason.
And there is something called the Fair Labor
Association that a lot of manufacturers have
joined and have been members of for a long
time.
And some companies like Gap kind of took a
while to kind of turn around and recognize
the benefit of being part of these types of
initiatives where they commit to basically
be audited for their labor standards and to
kind of be certified that they're not abusing
workers.
And Apple's been, I think they announced recently
that they are gonna join the FLA, but they've
been really resistant for the most part to
engage with the human rights community on
labor standards and it's one of an extremely
long list of troubling things about Apple
[laughs] that one might compile.
And then this question of sales of surveillance
technology I actually do deal with that in
the book as well although some of the major
news kind of came out after the book went
into the publisher.
But, yeah, absolutely, there are companies
that are profiting directly and knowingly
from the, it's basically arms sales to repressive
regimes essentially, and this is one reason
why this piece of legislation called The Global
Online Freedom Act has been revived kind of
in a new form in the past couple months.
And it's geared more than it was in the past
towards trying to constrain precisely this
type of export and this type of business relationship.
And the problem is, of course, it's hard because
a lot of this technology is also used for
legitimate security purposes or legitimate
network management purposes and you can market
it one way for a very repressive purpose and
then you can also market it in another way
and so how exactly you regulate it
is hard.
I mean one actually interesting development
is that, what was it Websense recently joined
the GNI and they're a filtering software company
and they say, "Look we're meant to help families
keep their children off of certain websites
and companies keep their employees from playing
on Facebook all day when they're supposed
to be working.
We're not meant to be used as a tool of political
repression and so we want to kind of commit
to, commit publicly to this notion that we
don't want our software to be used for political
repressive purposes.
And we're gonna work with investors and human
rights activists to kind of prevent that from
happening."
And they just joined so we're gonna kind have
to see how that evolves.
But I think it would be important for these
companies who produce equipment and software
that can be used, has this dual use function,
to make really robust commitments about what
their technology is intended for and what
it's not, and to make commitments not to sell
to regimes that obviously are gonna use it
in a particular way.
And I think it would be, you may be able to
regulate that to some extent and I think the
regulations actually moving towards SEC reporting
and this kind of thing so that investors will
understand more whether this company is behaving
responsibly.
But also the socially responsible investment
funds that are sort of gaining steam kind
of across the board are starting to look more
at these issues too.
And Boston Common, which is one of these funds,
they sold all their Cisco stock last year
because they were so mad that Cisco wouldn't
engage in dialog with them about how their
products were being used in China.
And so I think we're gonna start seeing more
investor activism and more push to kind of
require these types of companies to disclose
who they're selling to and to adopt policies,
kind of know your customer and that you have
to kind of track where it's going and where
it's being used and sell and market it responsibly.
But it's a really, it's a tough and troubling
issue.
Yep, you had a --
>>male #1: Can I go round again?
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah, sure, why not.
>>male #1: So taking a step beyond consent
of the governed, I think we have to think
about the informed consent --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>male #1: of the governed.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Absolutely, yeah.
>>male #1: One of the things that, if I may
wax political, the Republicans and the Taliban
have in common is --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>male #1: this clever idea
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: [laughs]
>>male #1: that if you abolish science education
--
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum.
>>male #1: and you abolish ethical education
then maybe people won't notice that we're
saying something weird here.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: [laughs]
>>male #1: And --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah, that is a problem.
>>male #1: here --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: [laughs]
>>male #1: on the corporate side here at Google
we have a rather peculiar position that it's
all very well to talk about the free market
but the notion of marketing undermines the
free market if you tell people what to buy
--
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>male #1: and you don't give them good opinions
then they'll act on the bad opinions --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah and you manipulate
them with kind of quasi --
>>male #1: Right.
So as we've stepped from a sort of informational
desert to more of an --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>male #1: informational blizzard what do
you think we can do structurally --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
>>male #1: in society to promote truth --
>>male #1: over political advantage?
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: That's a really, that
is subject of some other books by some really
smart people I know [laughs] and is a huge
matter of debate.
And this whole question of to what extent
do people care about facts is very troubling.
I completely agree.
And as a former journalist, I'm often, one
of the reasons I left CNN was because my managers
wanted me to do less to inform the public
than I was interested in doing and I was told
I should cover my region more like a tourist
and that my expertise was getting in the way
of kinds of stories they wanted on prime time
and so on.
Dumb myself down basically.
And so when the reason you go into journalism
is 'cause you think it's really important
for the public to be informed and then your
bosses say, "Well, we just want you to kinda
not really inform them that much," [laughs]
it's really depressing.
But my dear friend and colleague Ethan Zuckerman
is working on a book that I think will come
out in maybe a year or so.
In dealing with what he calls the caring problem
which is a related problem which is how do
you get people to pay attention to issues
that are important, and the importance of
actually engineering for it and structuring
your systems around the recognition that people
are probably gonna have a bias towards not
seeking out certain kinds of information or
a bias towards being susceptible to manipulation
and so on.
And so how do you engineer, and also just
kind of build online communities and platforms
that try to kind of move the caring problem,
kind of address the caring problem in the
other direction?
And that's one of the things we try to do
with Global Voices is just kind of make is
easier to access content from different countries
created by citizen journalists that's gonna
give you a different point of view than what
you're getting from the New York Times or
CNN, let alone Fox or whatever else, about
what's happening in whatever country it happens
to be.
But yeah I think it requires constant effort
because I think this is one of the problems,
one of the many bugs in human nature that's
so troubling [laughs] which is that, yeah,
we often times are more governed by emotions
and other things than we are by facts.
And so how do we kind of say, "Okay, rather
than what people should be, let's accept it
as a given all the bugs in the way people
are and try and compensate for that in the
way we build information products, news products,
and so on."
But it's really, really hard given, particularly
with for-profit news organizations being pushed
to, if you're gonna expand circulation or
ratings kind of ends of driving a lot of companies
in the opposite direction.
And so the extent to which we can kind of
build information communities and the extent
to which Google can kind of help bridge some
of these gaps, I think, is vitally important
now.
Anyway.
>>male #3: One of the things here at Google
most of the people here benefit tremendously
from a liberal democracy --
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Hum.
>>male #3: for our lives and we tend to build
systems that we like and unfortunately some
of those systems that we like we can deploy
them to the entire world instantaneously with
sometimes devastating results.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum, like with Buzz
or something.
yeah.
>>male #3: Yeah, I reread your article there.
So how do we temperate that and what's the,
I mean it's a difficult problem because one
person does have a tremendous amount of power
nowadays.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Um-hum, yeah.
>>male #3: And how do we check that?
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Yeah.
Well I think part of it is in, I think the
first step is recognizing this problem and
that something that's really cool and works
really well in the context of Mountain View
may play out really differently in Syria.
And, but there's actually people you can consult
with on that and you can talk to somebody
who's sort of part of that community and you
can, I mean, this is one reason why with the
Global Network Initiative why we advocate
that people run kind of human rights due diligence
and kind of human rights assessments.
When you're assessing a new product and how
it works you kind of game through, "Okay,
this is really great for us here in Mountain
View, but what if I am a dissident in Syria?
What are all the worse case scenarios that
might play out?
Let's try and run those through and figure
out how that could play out and talk to people
who've got experience using the Internet in
Syria."
Or, "How is that gonna play out in China?"
There are people you can talk to.
Or how does that play out with people who
are fleeing their abusive spouses or people
who don't want their sexual preference to
be known by their bosses, people who are maybe
not quite so far from home.
But I think the first step is just recognizing
that you can't know on your own, it's the
humility, I can't know on my own exactly how
this product is gonna play out around the
world amongst people whose experience is so
different from my own.
But the good news is that there are people
out there who wanna help you think that through
before you roll out the product and that you
can call upon them.
And so organizations like the Global Network
Initiative which Google joined, have, that's
kind of one interface where a company can
go to, to seek out the people you need to
consult with to make sure that there aren't
unintended consequences.
And so yeah I mean it was a really important
step with Google recognizing that Google has
a lot of geniuses but you can't anticipate
everything
and just having that kind of humility is real
important.
>>Female presenter: Just wanna thank you for
coming and talking with us.
>>Rebecca MacKinnon: Thank you.
[applause]
Great conversation.